she's rebelling i'm at the hotel where
i'm where are you me and my friend are
waiting where are you
[Music]
okay guys welcome back welcome back
welcome back to
sng
second best podcast on the planet yes er
we haven't said that in a while we
haven't said that we haven't said that
in a while but it still remains true
guys second best podcast on the planet
with your boys j money and fire lord
wakes and we are so happy to have you
here and if you like being here and
you've been here for a while you already
know what to do but i'm gonna remind you
once more you know the vibes to pause
the episode right now head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits in gigs
and from there guys you are going to
enjoy our company every thursday as well
as every monday you get two days off and
then we're back in it again
inside your ear holes pause
the episode
[Music]
yeah you were ready for that so
everyone's working on different levels
today
so guys for just three pound a month 10p
a day you gotta run the p to s g and
then that's how you're gonna become a
cult baby do you hear me
what's going on i don't know it's just
fluid
um
mine's coming up with double on tom
white robin yeezy is the uniform for
this cult guys and if you want to get
involved you know what you need to do
head on over to patreon enjoy all the
backlog of content as well as a new
episode every thursday and get involved
with the vibes over there guys if you're
watching us on youtube please like the
video if you liked the video chirps are
painting in the comments hangers chirps
of penguins in the comments
and subscribe and use the notification
bell guys we really really really
appreciate it it means a lot we're
trying to grow this cult to worldwide
status and we need you to do it okay
foot soldiers that's what you men are
doing
um and obviously you guys
you know wait this is where this is
where the og's come in guys the true
podcast fans we're talking about the
audio listeners we talk about the
spotify dance the apple apple uh podcast
dance we're talking about the google
podcast on amazon amazon
wherever you get your sweet mellow vibes
from guys please if you are listening
right now just take a second to
subscribe to the channel give us a nice
review and preferably a five-star rating
it means everything to us we're not just
saying that we know everyone says it oh
it means the world to us it actually
does mean everything to us it does um so
please give us a nice star rating it
helps spread the word and um keep this
cold going guys okay um so
before we get into who has fun facts if
you guys were with us last week um you
wouldn't know actually no two weeks ago
now it was that uh fuji went on a crazy
rant about menu for about literally half
an hour yeah i edited it up and it was i
said that the days i think that was a
half an hour it was exactly half an hour
okay that as passionate so just quick i
heard on the news the other day your
boys um you're not the only one who
feels this way
i'm hearing your boys are writing of
shutting down games writing because
they're just they can't handle the
brains
brotherhood
bro they want the glazers out give us
our team back
give us us free
they want them out and
the thing is obviously this comes out
later than obviously what's happening
right now but um
what i read somewhere was like because
the players and like united as a team as
a business aren't reaping all the
rewards the glazers have been sucking
money from i swear i think it said last
year they took a couple billion off them
oh my god stupid like that yeah so
the only the only thing that's happening
right now that's kind of like getting
the glazes off everyone getting everyone
off the glazers back is
what i said a few weeks ago about uh the
cronkite's arsenal's owners giving
architecture just fees just giving them
funds yeah yeah get who you need
i think only just recently now
um
they've given
they've given united i think 300 mil to
spend in the because the wait they're
trying well by the time this comes out
the transfer would have closed but it
closes in a few weeks okay
um and we've bought we've just bought
one player we've got um casimiro who's a
midfielder from real madrid
um baller he used to play with ronaldo i
need to play with iran so we'll see how
that how that pans out and he plays with
fred in the national team and we're
trying to get a guy called anthony who
used to play who currently plays for ix
who use who's manager used to be our
current manager yeah breaks in hard and
blah blah so and that's from roughly
between 70 100 m so we'll see and he
still wants at least two more players
like he wants the gut the whole time
which is what needs to happen yeah
that's what needs to happen so yeah i
feel like
um he's the glazers have given
um the fans a small window of
opportunity like here's a couple more
m's buy whatever you need to buy so we
can start winning games and shut the
[ __ ] up yeah that's basically what that
is yeah shut up money
if you don't win more games now
leave me out of business your business
about 500 m's this channel yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah if you can't win games
look at your manager yeah
yeah i mean that's that's that's what
that money is yeah yeah yeah yeah so
we'll see why i bet we'll see you while
going oh [ __ ] hell but um yeah um
as like i keep saying but i'm watching
the game tonight but obviously because
it's so far ahead um there's this
recording
i just need to
hope and pray that we beat liverpool
swear hope and pray that would be
livable yeah
i hope for you bro i hope for you uh
because this is uh it's sounding drastic
dangerous territory bro um just to like
double down as well remember i was
saying to you um when we spoke about uh
what went on the rant rather um arsenal
lost their first three games blah blah
so they won their first three games this
season now and
they're playing
i hate talking about arsenal but they're
playing so well
and it's it's
annoying yeah it's so annoying because
it's the arsenal of back a day yesterday
yeah yeah and
the arsenal of back a day they were
different well i remember i was
different i was thinking today actually
when's the last time when when was i
actually balls deep in football football
um i was a kid and this is but yeah i
was bored in football in the arsenal
heyday this is before
the this is before the chelsea run
the big big chelsea run when they had
their three four years yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and way before the man
city office this is where mad city were
dog [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah of
course they still had like show right
phillips
but this was yeah i'm talking it was my
new arsenal team
uh and i remember also my stepdad was a
massive [ __ ] arsenal fan and every
weekend we'll watch arsenal nice thing
[ __ ] yeah they're playing they play they
play football they played
like they had like a very
they had a very french flair to their
course of course bro sleek when you had
man like robert perez you had man like
obviously thierry on rio you had um
taran you had
you had so many french players in that
squad yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like and
obviously being sierra he's an
influencer bro he was he was or is the
one of the best players to play he used
to play fancy football fancy fancy
football and also man you used to play
sturdy football we just english yeah
english football
sausage and egg football
so it was always a battle yeah ryan
giggs pool skulls football bro yeah yeah
yeah i was football
after that it's a good thing you did
because you don't have the heartache i
have yeah
and it's it's just it's it's so annoying
to watch we can week out your peers and
other people doing so good and when it
comes to your game you think on paper we
should demolish at least
95 of the premier league yeah yeah yeah
yeah and we're getting tucked in week
and week out yeah yeah my um
my
how do i like my underdog team of the
season has fallen
um they went down two seasons oh they
went down a few seasons ago i only just
come back this season
and the thing with uh mitch vic is their
number nine who's their striker um he
bangs like i want to say 40-something
goals in the championship which is the
division for those i don't know the
championship is the division underneath
the premier league the premier league is
the top division so he banged that
40-something goals when they were in the
um championship last season and the
season before that or two seasons before
that that's when they're in the premier
league i think he only banged like three
or five goals maybe and everyone was
saying he can't replicate what he does
in the championship in the premier
league for obvious reasons the premier
league is a lot tougher the players
everything is different you know the
stage is big there everything some
people can pressure you can't handle
that
so
the first game liverpool played they
liverpool the first game fulham played i
think they played liverpool when they
drew two two mitchelovich scored both
goals oh gang
the second game they played
i can't remember what the score was but
i think they won
three two i wouldn't no that was just
this this week ago again this comes out
wherever but um
they will draw in two two against
brentford yeah and mitchellville scored
the winner three two in the 90th minute
so he's already backed three goals and
he in two games in two games and he
could have bagged at least two in the
second game but he he just missed out
yeah yeah he played well okay you know
what i mean
he's yeah
he's getting good with it he's getting
very good with it and fulham as a team
fulham newcastle brighton i want to say
those three
are
they're playing as if
they're playing as if there's 10 games
in a season and they've won their first
three and they're trying they're going
they're [ __ ] going for it do you know
what i mean that's how them free play is
yes and it's good to see yeah because it
brings underdog football it brings so
much to figuring it's so i was saying to
bella a few weeks ago because it was um
newcastle versus west ham and i said to
her the week before that this is going
to be a very good game yeah because the
way newcastle are playing especially at
home
they are bawling and not necessarily
just they're not balling out of control
but you can tell they found something in
their system this season and the tail
end of last season they were winning 3-1
and they drew 3-3 against man city oh
exactly i was like i knew this was going
to be a good game they were in the lead
3-1
wow
unlucky to let it slip but it's still a
good game [ __ ] yeah
i love stuff like that so i love i love
like even playing fields yes bro that's
what nba used to be
before we started getting to this
all-star team italian yeah um that's
what that's the french league psg bro
psg obviously everyone knows who's paris
saint-germain they've they are the best
team in france or they have as long as
you've gotten bapped neymar and messi on
one team
what else do you want they beat lil the
other day 7-1
like come on bro yeah come on now what's
the point yeah let's even this up this
is boring point what's the point there's
no one
even having like five top teams is
boring like you want to have the whole
table just doing a rush
i think this season will be a very good
season bro in terms of the table it's
going to be a very very good season say
less that's why like that's why people
love like um the playoffs in the nba
because anyone anyone's game yeah
and then you'll see man that are like in
the like their conference finals
and they're bowling yeah they're they've
never been there
you've never seen that stage this last
playoffs with um who's the conference
final celtics and golden state was it i
didn't watch this seas this last last
season was the conference finals celtics
and it was definitely cervix because
tatum yeah
yeah
yeah tatum's one of the most underrated
players jason he's one of the most under
he has been for years okay one of the
most underrated ballers in the nba okay
he's just a [ __ ] unit okay and he's
just like
i don't know he just never really gets i
don't really know what it is that he
never really gets the attention but
everyone just knows he's a hooper but
like no one says anything really about
him he's never like he makes all-star
games and he's just like uh he's a
franchise player for the celtics but
like he's never really in that like top
three contender okay conversations in
the league but when he
when you see him on the court you think
[ __ ] what position does he play uh he is
a
destination is what position does jason
tatum play
i wanna say he's a
perhaps powerful i was going to say he's
a power forward but um he handles a ball
uh jason tatum
i was gonna say he's either a shooting
guard or a power forward but then this
is when i found out he's a [ __ ] point
guard because he point guards are
different yeah he's um
he does it all i swear
i just googled it yeah people are asking
questions yeah different yeah different
seasons he's played different um so he's
moving
yeah small forwards um small forward
power forward yeah he does it all okay
he does it all he's a yeah he's a
[ __ ] baller bro okay um
but yeah anyway that's why i love that's
what
i do still love it but yeah that
that's the way that like the american
things with nfl is the way the american
systems are set to run that just like
across the board any team can
do it and then because it's all
centralized um obviously the owners have
do have influence in terms of like
players and stuff like that uh in the
nba a lot of the the funds and the picks
and stuff are centralized so
whoever finishes last
in the season
gets the first pick
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah of the
rookie yeah yeah so then it can
it can flip the flop immediately um but
now there's like they've always done it
but now there's a massive influence in
terms of trading picks okay
which kind of [ __ ] with the system so
the the i don't think they should be
allowed to do it um but basically
people have their pick and then they
will
they add their pick as like another
bargaining tool as well as like a trade
so black oh we'll give you for your
player we'll trade you these two players
and next year's pick
um
yeah and then they'll do stuff like that
i don't think they should be allowed to
trade picks hey i think it should be
allowed to trade players but picks is
just a different thing yeah yeah but
anyway i'm not to make this another
sports podcast last week but um yeah
let's do the fun fact oh yeah cool
uh fun fact of the day guys right
maths teacher found with photos of
students
in swimwear during lessons
i saw this title
i didn't read into it
male maths teacher i'm assuming
i'm assuming let me just read yeah okay
go on go go go
every paragraph gets worse oh jesus
christ okay go on
a math teacher in london has been struck
off after being found with photos of
former students in swimwear
according to my london james eldon 29
had been teaching an online maths class
when around 5 of the 17 students he saw
that he had pictures of former pupils in
bikinis
one former student reportedly said what
shocked me the most was that he was my
maths teacher
it's been said that eldon had also been
found to be watching porn at school and
had a relationship with a former student
the teacher who taught the school sorry
the teacher who taught at the school
from september 2016 to february 2021
before being exposed has admitted to all
the accusations against him
after an iit investigation which which
was launched it was discovered that mr
eldon sent a pupil a message that read i
love you the most oh dear during the
summer holidays
another student also anonymously
contacted the head teacher and it became
known that eldon had a romantic
relationship with her
though elden admitted that he that the
two kissed he said that the relationship
was not sexual and that he ended it
after admitted to watching porn on his
personal laptop during the school day
and searching for photos of students an
investigation found that he had been
doing so during the teaching hours as
well
bro so not only was my man not only did
he
needs bathing suit pics
[ __ ] nose just asking
[ __ ] knows because that's that's a
territory you don't want to step into
oh so not only did he have pics on his
phone of
students in bikinis he lips a couple of
them he told them i love you the most
the most
during the holidays you're in a school
mind your business right during my
school holiday yeah don't message me
nothing during my school holiday bro i'm
on an escape
leave me the [ __ ] alone why do you have
my number yeah honestly
you know what i mean rags this is a
breach
it's a big gdpr breach fam
wow between the between the years of
2016 and 2021 he was just moving he was
moving nuts watching porn on shift jesus
christ that's
this is crazy that
he got himself into like i would i'd
obviously
it's gross regardless
but i would expect something like this
to have happened
years ago
like this is 2016 to 2021 like
in terms of security in terms of like
social media in terms of all of these
things in terms of background checks in
terms of continuous background checks
like yearly due diligence
how are they not how has it taken
five years to realize that a teacher has
been doing this in your school i could
never be that teacher yeah bro
i'm assuming bear these girls just
didn't say [ __ ] of course they didn't
they were shook you're either shook or
gasped or get down one of the one of
those down
and and that's
that is
like men like that shouldn't be anywhere
near kids probably that's you never know
in it if they've never you do your
background checks you do all these
things they've never had any flags as
long as they've never been caught
there's nothing to find so then they
just moved mad there was a guy when i
was in school there was a pee teacher
from another school
who was banging a student
he was banging a student no oh yes a pe
teacher from another school was banging
a student from his school yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah how did you find out of course
how did i find it yeah yeah oh it went
around yeah it went around but even
before he got sacked that rumor was
going around for time oh for like two
years before he got sick
yes bro all the students in my school
knew because he was the county
he made picks for county basketball okay
and i remember the first year he came to
watch me he didn't [ __ ] pick me and i
was livid okay and i remember saying i
remember thinking in my head [ __ ] this
peter yeah what does he know
about this guy i swear to god i remember
being fixed but i'm not going to tell a
teacher yeah yeah it's all hearsay yeah
and then i was thinking i swear that's
the bread
bangs like you like girls at his school
um but bear time like it's weird as well
because you also when you're a kid you
don't acknowledge it in terms of like
he's banging
in my head i'm pretty sure he was
banging like a year 11 girl when i was
in like year eight or nine and when i'm
in year eight or nine year 11 girls are
basically adults to me of course of
course when you see them
they're older they're banging so i'm
thinking of course he's slamming
girls he shouldn't be doing it it's
wrong but why wouldn't he
they're banging
and they're mature and they're older
than me
so if they're down and he's down i don't
i don't why that is going on yeah [ __ ]
him obviously because you shouldn't be
doing that because you're a teacher but
i didn't see it as like oh you're
grooming and you're like
yeah you're like a child molester like i
didn't think about that i was thinking
you're just banging
you're not only in control of my dreams
and my life
you're also scooping up all the lengths
yeah so you can [ __ ] off yeah but then
when i was older it was probably like
year 10 that i was in that when i heard
that he actually got sacked and that was
the reason why i got sacked and stuff
i'm thinking
okay did i expose who the girl was no i
have no idea who the girl was that's mad
man yeah it's
because my my issue not necessarily well
issue not issue because it doesn't
whatever
it's one of those ones where
let's say for example this spreader was
um grooming someone that was in year 11.
yeah yeah so 16.
the thing is i was going to say
something so outlandish
and say
how do
they not know when i say they mean like
the women how did they not know
that this is a [ __ ] bad idea the
girls yeah but then i just like think i
don't remember what i was doing at 16.
oh yeah bro and i would add girls we
spoke about this longer there were girls
in my class that were dating like old
men yeah yeah
very true very true and like i knew
girls in like year 11 year 10 wherever
that fancy teachers there was one music
teacher that we had called i can't
remember his name but he was the son of
another teacher i think and he was
literally like 1920 21 maybe the girls
in my class were gasps of him just
because he was not ugly yeah and a
teacher yeah and a young teacher they
were [ __ ] one million percent if you
kept them after class and just put moves
on there 100 would have [ __ ] him one
million percent that's that the girls
aren't thinking oh this is wrong this is
wrong they think i've patted a old guy
yeah true i'm not asking questions true
because girls in my year were dating
that 21 22 year olds that was skanky
bald weirdos that are hanging outside
the school gates
so if they were patented a peng teacher
yeah security dental
dental yeah they'll suck him off
[ __ ] it's disgraceful bro [ __ ] it's
disgraceful that's such a
that's such a mental power play
that it's
it's clear that
men that do do that ie go for like such
young prey
they can't handle women like they can't
handle someone making their own
decisions yeah yeah yeah they can't
handle
like chat back chat yeah yeah they can't
handle any of that it's like they have
to find someone and literally groom them
yeah dude you thought that's
that's psychotic
bro it's nuts it's not fun
um [ __ ] but yeah that's yeah [ __ ] that
guy for sure yeah that was a bear that
goes on and then you've obviously got
the laying teachers that just slop off
got like the kids
oh the female teachers oh my god which
was never a thing we were in school it
was it's never going to happen in
england
and when we were growing up it wasn't
there was no banging teacher when we
yeah in my heyday yeah in my younger
years there was no banging teacher bro
there were i yeah i think i told you one
time we had one banging supply teacher
one time for one week
teacher one polish
banging she didn't look at us
she didn't look i was on year 11. she
weren't looking at us no she's not don't
give a [ __ ]
we were out here playing quick cricket
around
year 11 if not maybe not nowadays but
when we were growing up year 11 between
like year 9 and year 11
we're still small and scrawny pathetic
if you go to america in year 11. they
eat they eat steroids for breakfast they
eat bricks yeah over there
that men are wet
no wonder they get sucked off in
secondary school by teachers do you know
what i mean because they're adults
already yeah they've got muscles already
bro we were used in year 11. they got
nothing wrong scrawny five foot two
teachers with a six foot four 16 year
old oh yeah they're getting bent over
they get bent over after school yeah and
then someone's i don't know who's
telling tales
who's snitching i do not the one that's
not getting sucked off yeah yeah i would
say rags i would snitch rags they're
[ __ ] one night chick that i was
giving blowies in the oh felicia
one-eyed felicia yeah bro reminded me of
her reminded me as well i was having
this conversation
last night on the playstation
um
because we realized quickly on the group
chat that different schools in different
areas have different cultures okay so
this is interesting one uh
in high school did you go to a public
high school
i went to two
from like let's say yeah year ninety
year eleven yes yes public high school
yes in dagenham yes okay bet
so amongst oh the the gossip
between those years let's push it like
year 11. okay
what any bread is getting sucked off
or was it anyone eating pum
no one was eating pork that's for sure
no family that is for sure
no one was eating [ __ ] i tell you that
for free
no one was eating [ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] if you got caught saying you ate
[ __ ] and you're in heaven
[Music]
but no but i know i the thing is i know
mando are getting head really
and no way jealous
i i never felt anything like it yeah
bro really really was getting sucked off
when you're 11 by year 11 girls oh rags
yeah yes bro did it was it public
knowledge who these girls were yes bro
nah and the girls were just allowed to
just go into the cafeteria
oh not during school no no i don't mean
sucking off during school okay i just
meant i just mean in general yeah bro it
was general knowledge that these girls
in your school were sucking off the
man's yeah bro
and they didn't get any trouble for it
raw not to be fair not that i can
remember about getting in trouble not
that i can remember but i know for a
fact because bro yeah this is the kind
of conversation
this is kind of a conversation in my
entire yeah if we were in year 11 yeah
and the black girls in my year heard
that you were sucking tall
you would never hear that you're a witch
you're a [ __ ] and a witch and we're
going to expose you
bro the same way man just can't go
around saying
[ __ ]
yeah there is no way any girl could ever
ever find out that another girl on you
was sucking dick
no
way
no way and
i wouldn't be able to stomach hearing
from one of my boys yeah that he got
sucked off by his girlfriend yeah in
year 11 i would have cried i would have
cried myself to sleep i was jealous that
these men were fingering yes
squeezing tea oh i squeezed
untold amounts about your teeth during
my yesterday as well that's all i had
yeah that's all we could do you do
second base that's it second base and a
young list
tender lips
and please don't feel how hard i am yeah
because it's embarrassing
but yeah i'm hearing that some of these
girls were sucking man off and i think
that never happened in my school and if
it did it was a it was a
hush huh
a secret
because i always remember uh
i was in science class i was telling the
story yesterday i was in science class
one day
and one of i might saw it on here before
there was a girl in a year above me yeah
um there was a girl yeah above me that
must have been in that class before us
and accidentally left her bag so
the fast girls in my year saw there was
a lone bag that didn't belong to anyone
in this class decided to rummage through
it yeah because
bastards yeah yeah bastards everyone's a
bastard bastard
rummage through it found out the girl
who whose bag it was
and found yesterday's knickers in there
so they hop skipped and jumped to
conclusions i'm like i'll swear she must
have stayed at her man's house last
night and just bought spare undies this
[ __ ]
wow
they took underwear
pinned it to the notice board
with like a sticker with her bait her
name is saying i'm getting such and such
is a slag
wow they were laughing who had laughing
the girl was crying
wow she came back to get a bag saw the
whole thing the girl was crying teacher
can say nothing
wow
just for finding spare underwear in her
bag
so when i tell you
if there were rumors of someone's
[ __ ] dick
no way in hell
would that ever
ever go like unscathed yeah never in a
million years
so to hear that it must
yeah i don't know what's going on
because one of the breads
so one of the brands that we were
talking to
was from
no one was allowed to suck dick yeah
one of the prayers was from brixton yeah
no one was allowed to think
well one of them uh is from reading
everyone sucked dick
and everyone was eating puss i'll swear
they do what they want in reading
apparently where so yours is a bit
you're stacking them at 50 50.
but when i tell you no one was eating
[ __ ]
between the years 9 and 11.
no one bro
no one i even till for me even until
like
even after college
no one was allowed when did i you were
the first person who openly told me
you were you were shouting smack you
were telling i was god smacked i was
thinking
whoa so do i but shut the [ __ ] up
we just met
bro
how have you got this level of
confidence man yeah he [ __ ] rags and i
was like what the [ __ ] yeah college gave
me i started putting in college yeah
yeah you went to boarding school in
college yeah i bet everyone was doing
awesome i think people were eating
boarding school i didn't eat ass until
when's the first time i asked
probably a few years ago oh yeah
probably deep into my 20s yeah yeah yeah
yeah arsenals
yeah
yeah i didn't have that kind of yeah
yeah yeah even because yeah even in you
can you imagine can you imagine you're
hearing that james ate ass last night
now would you i wouldn't have heard the
end of it bro your face would have been
pinging around dbm
rc uh
james got the [ __ ] mouth light skin
james got the doo doo mouth yo they
would have torn you up they would have
told me apart but in secret my bbm's
would have been pop poppin
fan poppin yeah
the amanda will never let me hear the
end of it but in secret the yeah would
be blowing me up blowing you up
wow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they love it
they love it oh dear really
no one was eating put me year 11 boy i
couldn't
i couldn't have imagined the in the
insults madden would have received oh i
remember my best friend telling me the
first time he ate pum
when we were 17 and i was literally
gobsmacked
he was like oh do you know what i did
last night and i was like what is that
oh i ate her because he had a girlfriend
yeah
he didn't say eight we didn't even say
eight yeah what did you say uh what do
you say i um
what would you call it
because you definitely weren't saying i
ate [ __ ]
because even the term eight at that time
i would have been like good lord
probably like licked palm oh little
round yeah yeah i licked her out
and i was like so where
why
why would you do something
because i remember the first time i ate
pum i remember the first time i opened i
wasn't even i was with my girlfriend at
the time it wasn't even like um i wasn't
even lost in the moment i was i bet you
i was gone yeah i was gone i ate pumble
as if i've been eating i've been eating
did you know me no not me boy mine was a
lizard like take
i was just like a very like experimental
she slot me off that was the first time
she'd ever put a dick in her mouth it
was terrible head okay i wasn't lost in
any kind of moment and like
we spoke and it was kind of like oh do
you want me to try something she was
like yeah try it and then like i was
very much like uh
oh that's lovely yeah oh how does that
feel and she was like
yeah like whatever um
it was a while after that until i was
eating pum because i was in goalkeeper
yeah yeah yeah i was in golf from the
jump from the champ bro
yeah i was sincere i think you're 12
yeah definitely it was definitely your
12th first on april
fair play in there bro yeah i was in
there
fair play brother don't care bro
i didn't care
what is going on guys let's take a very
very very very quick break to
pay some bills and
spread the love on our culti sponsor
man escapes okay guys so when we're in
the log cabin everyone needs those
smooth sacks okay
and the only way we're gonna get those
smooth sacks is with the new man escape
product guys who asked for it and they
listened
they've just brought out the ultra
smooth package to europe guys okay
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower
4.0 is the best electric shave for your
balls but if you're looking for a closer
shave
or prefer to go completely bare down
there
ultra smooth package is for the is the
perfect set it's time to shave that bush
of yours and get right to the roots
right to the roots by going to
manskate.com and for 20 off plus free
shipping please use the code sng sierra
november golf that's sng sierra november
gold manskit.com 20 off plus free
shipping and then the ultra smooth
package can be yours guys thank you very
much
let's get back to the juicy episode
today
gang um right i've got uh before we move
on yeah hit me i've got a scenario so
just a question for you so do you
remember when we did that spotify cafe
thing yes and then ash asked us for a
million quid will we split up yes a
million each or whatever
and we said nah yes we'll be foolish
whatever
made me think what number
would you not each what number if
someone was to approach you and be like
we love what you're doing just in a
secret thing okay we love what we're
doing
but yeah james needs to go
he's dragging you down bro we've done
our research he's dragging you down
but we're going to need to end this
amicably so what we're going to need you
to do give us a number we've got your
studio set up
we've got your guests ready
give us a number and you're gonna have
to lock james off
so they will pay me a certain amount to
lock you off
and do the foo hat show
[ __ ]
[ __ ] um
oh
[ __ ]
i hate these sort of questions
um
the thing is i don't even have a
ballpark figure because
i would it would still be seven figures
but what i would say i would say
something outlandish i'll say something
outlandish like maybe 10 m's and then
obviously haggle haggle haggle blah blah
let's let's say they drop it down to
five i'll take five
but i wouldn't take the five i'll give
the five to you now you're not to give
me anything why because i'm gonna make
profit off the other thing so i'll give
the five to you nah that's part of the
deal you can't give me just five m's
i have to take the p and just cut you
off p and cut me off
[ __ ] that's a bit tough
i mean i wouldn't even want the p
that's cute bro i appreciate that
but there is a number yeah
there actually isn't a number so 100 m's
i mean that's
anyone would say yes to 100 mm for
anything do you know what i mean
rags so there's obviously going to be
there's going to be a spectrum
there you say there's obviously
numbers there's numbers to the point
where you're like i don't even want that
i wouldn't even want it i wouldn't even
want it but then we'll get to a number
whether it's 30 40 50 60 m's i know for
a fact you would do it for 20 m's yeah i
already said 10 m's though yeah that
hurt my feelings i'm not gonna lie to
you you said ten and you said you'd
settle on five yeah but it's because
cause i my assumption was to give it to
you anyway so you wouldn't even give me
ten
you're like no no five no no i said ten
and they would haggle so i'll settle for
five that's what i said run it back and
rewind it that's what i said yeah yeah
yeah yourself to five to give me five
yeah because that's shut up money it's
not shut up man you should have money to
james take your five and be happy with
it five m's yeah it's big but that's
minor for the rest of my life
my career
what am i supposed to do from here
invest
don't ask me stupid questions [ __ ]
invest it that's five m's we're talking
about that five games is a light
because i want to live lavish forever
five minutes is not gonna do it
[ __ ] sake um um okay
oh then it's still irrelevant because i
can't give you the money
so
i'll still stick with 10 bro 10 m's 10 m
drop me off 10 ms
wow that's low still how is that that's
10 million pounds brother
how is that low
how is that low what would you say how
much would you say oh probably like uh
maybe like 30 m's
maybe not 25 30 amps
i mean there's there is a huge
difference there has to be that much
difference between 10 and 30. because
that's what i said there is a huge
difference yeah yeah but 10
you can't say you're not going to live
lavish for with 10 m's for the rest of
your life yeah yeah i'm i would live
leverage with 10 enterprise but i'm
saying in terms of like the reason i
would i'm picking such a high number
because in order for me to do it it
would have to be such an outlandish
figure that i think
if i stay with food and we grind for
years we're never getting this much
money we're getting 10 m's
you're gonna see 10 m's in this career
so
in my head i'm thinking if they said 10
m's i'm thinking um i reckon if we grind
for like three four years we'll see 10
m's anyway okay and i don't have to stab
my friend in the back so i don't know
again it has to be a number where i'm
like oh we're never getting that okay
no matter what okay
okay but it's fine you said what you
said anyway shut up um
shut up
all right i've got a fan request okay
cool so fan request number one so i'm
going to do two foundations back to back
here yeah yeah number one
uh a young man messaged in and said guys
i need help
i met a girl on hinge all was going well
she came over after a bit and damn
catfish
i thought you were going to say damn
loud
[ __ ] yeah okay i'm interested now okay
hit me hit me hit me so man said anyway
before i know it i've gone and told her
about a gig that i'm playing with my
band okay now she's now she's booked a
hotel near the venue
and says she's coming with her mate
i do not want her to come
one because i don't like her and two
because i've already invited another
girl to come as well
i don't want to call it off with her
after meeting her once as we [ __ ] and
i don't want to be that guy
uh oh wait there's a bit more okay um
she's also promised that her mate is
looking to get laid and wants my drummer
but i showed him a picture
and he hated it so much he asked me to
take it out of the group chat
wow
literally
wow
human doesn't even want in his media
yeah he's not going to see it again
bro this
imagine me putting the group bro there's
this girl i'm talking to she said her
brethren is dtf are you down
you are you down i show you a picture
and you say first of all not only am i
not down please delete that out of this
[ __ ] group chat because if i have to
open whatsapp and just see that again
i'm gonna be sick
wow
bro do you know the maddest thing about
men
he still piped her yeah
why did you pipe her exactly now you're
in this position of course she's going
to want to come and of course dead oh i
feel bad i don't want to lock her off
because i did [ __ ] her man said i was
talking to her on hinge she came through
wow fish catfish and still and then i
bagged her
what is wrong with people
he thought i might as well she's here
anyway yeah she's here anyway i might as
well [ __ ] then you [ __ ] her now
you're lost in this situation oh he
found he found one attribute one
attribute and ran with it and now he
can't even go to her and be like i'm
really really really sorry but please
don't come to my gig because i'm just
not really feeling it i'm not attracted
to you she was like why did you [ __ ] me
then fax why did you [ __ ]
why don't you just tell me that when we
met i messed up because i was horny and
alone
i was horny
i didn't think anyone else would find
out yeah and i didn't think you would
double down and bring a friend yes bro
and now it's even worse because you're
you're bringing a friend expecting her
to get piped and my friend said yuck no
way ew he said
take her out of our group chat yeah get
a picture of my site and now i'm
associated with a girl that i don't like
that also has a friend that's butters
yeah so now my boys think i can't pull
girls that's exactly what's happening
right it's a situation that we're in and
now i'm stuck with you and your bedroom
who i can't
pay someone to [ __ ]
wow
what do i do
wow and i've got another thing coming
he's got another two income have you
both in the
building the thing is he can't depending
on he's a is a musician yeah yeah yeah
depending on the size of the venue it's
going to be a small venue
no offense
but regardless regardless
even in a small standing venue at
concert like if i'm in the top left and
she's at the back right you're never
going to see each other you're never
going to see each other unless you like
go to the bot whatever and you're never
going to know oh this is that person and
that's that person yeah of course so
he could
he could
patent like both of them to come
secure the main one that he wanted to
bring and just ignore the other one i
mean he could do that i'm not saying you
should do that i'm saying he could do
that but
he needs to
he needs to speak to this chick
depending on how close this gig is
from she said she booked a hotel near
the vehicle i forgot about that so even
if he patterns this news
me and my friend are waiting where are
you where's the drummer
we're trying to [ __ ] what's going on i
booked this hotel specifically you know
where it's at i booked it specifically
near the venue man said take her out the
group chat
that is an insult and a half james i've
never seen or heard anything like it
let's see from five i could never show
you take this down and you say bro no
offense get out
get her out of this chat
i wouldn't know what else to say to you
if i've said that to you i wouldn't know
what else to say because i'm thinking
how dare you bring that in the chat how
do you think i'll be attracted to that
how dare you
and it's also going to be one of them
ones where it's like i already know
you've got a penguin
yeah
and how dare you even negotiate that
with me
bro it's long that's not going to last
long not even being dread i've probably
already told you the maine is a it's a
catfish so you're probably thinking so
what's going on
what's actually happening here so hang
on hang on hang on let me get this
straight you've got your catfish and
you're trying to finesse me with her
butters friends oh this is lock her up
downward spiral we're meant to be boys
yeah yeah you're doing this to me
i couldn't i wouldn't be able to look at
you james yes
that's not honest get out of my face bro
oh that is shocking but you have to tell
her you have to there's no you just have
to rip the bandaid off because as peak
as it sounds you [ __ ] him when you
definitely shouldn't have you should
have told her from the jump
but just because you [ __ ] someone guys
all get guys and girls just because you
[ __ ] someone it doesn't mean you owe
them anything remember that as well yeah
unless you were lying to her to get her
in bed yeah two different stories two
different stories i don't know how what
i don't know what led up to the fact
that she came to your yard but all
you've told us was you guys were talking
on hinge she came through she was a
catfish but you smashed anyway because
you're an [ __ ] but
just like i said male or female just
because two consenting people have sex
it doesn't mean they owe you anything
yeah you need to remember that so
regardless of how it may make her feel
and regardless of how
rude it might sound
the best and honest thing for you to do
is just being mantella
yo
either a i don't think you should come
or be
listen
i know we had sex blah blah blah blah
blah blah all these things happened but
i feel like
it's just not for me yeah bro like it's
just not for me not for me and i was
lost in the moment and we had a good
time and i think you're nice but like
i really don't see it going anywhere and
i'm just offered to pay for her hotel or
something yes
look let me pay for the hotel if you i'd
love you to still come
but on a friend team yeah exactly
because i really don't see this going
anywhere and like i don't want to give
you the wrong impressions and false like
expectations and now you're sending me
your girl who's trying to get banged and
it's just it's too much
yeah yeah i don't want to be an [ __ ]
look let me pay for your hotel
regardless if you come or not if you do
come great if you don't come i
understand but i think we should just be
boys from here yeah uh and she'll be
like ra okay whatever you're sh she's
gonna think you're a prick of course
that's the game is the game that's
literally the dice you rolled and the
easiest thing about all of this is
you're doing it via hinge like or at
what's happening
at this point yeah just message this and
just message her the whole thing don't
message her in bits and bobs and wait
for it message of the whole one
yeah and just put your phone away yeah
yeah yeah yeah you've done what you have
to do one paragraph don't say
babe
and then when you start yeah yeah yeah
no no no no no because if she comes
online yeah it's wrong for you
it's a lot cause you're not gonna really
say what you wanna say because you're
going to [ __ ] out she's reading it in
real time yeah and you're going to [ __ ]
out so yeah yeah say it send the whole
thing in one paragraph and then just
keep it moving oh 100 if anything type
it in your notes then copy and paste it
into what's happening
worst case scenario is once you send it
you leave it five minutes and she
[ __ ] bells you oh my god that's what
my heart would sink that's worse
as well my heart would [ __ ] sink as
well you send it switch your phone off
100
do not disturb immediately immediately
half an hour at least go for a nervous
[ __ ]
have a shower come out check it she's
there's either gonna be missed calls on
there or whatever and just
oh god i'm getting actually anxious i'm
actually getting anxious
i'm actually getting [ __ ] anxious
what's worse
heart left do not disturb left at half
an hour you come back you switch off
your do not disturb you've got missed
calls go low okay let's say you've got
four missed calls and two tags
or
switch off do not step and it's one of
them ones where you can see she's lost
the last scene on her thing
no response nothing just cold
what's worse
the cause
okay um i would be a bit nervous about
the no response nothing but like no
response like next day no response day
after that no response your show has
come and gone no response oh that's
perfect scenario okay yeah that's
perfect
okay but if it's been like 10 15 minutes
and she's i know she's seen it yeah and
there's no response i would be a little
bit nervous but if i come out shout out
to miss cause
i'll be terrified
i'll be terrified yeah if anything i'll
just be more honest and message her
again and be like look look i was in the
shower to be fair i wasn't ignoring your
calls but i've just come out this hour
and seen you been calling me big man
stop i'm not mad enough to have this
conversation over the phone
i'm really not so please take what i
said for gold because i meant that yeah
i meant that just know that once we
speak it's not gonna get better yeah so
please just take what i said and take it
away
take everything away
because i can't deal with this oh i've
got a gig to focus on
there's money to be made
i can't i can't handle both
yeah bro [ __ ] that jokes that's a oh
that's terrifying catfish and he wants
to bring the friend oh you shouldn't
have banged her brother yeah you
shouldn't have banged her you're a fool
bro
you're in now yeah begging [ __ ] it you
[ __ ] it yeah absolutely [ __ ] up
right i've got one more as well yeah
right so man said
a little bit about me
i'm 18
5 8
moderately good looking on a good day
i also play basketball and i'm in shape
okay so that's a plus and i think it's
relevant
but
man i said i'm having girl
problems
times 1000
but not how all my mates have them
so
i may all right
just context when i read this sent me in
a whirlwind of
frustration and
and
frustration sympathy and like you'll
know as i'm saying okay cool eye rolling
okay right different emotions yeah
different emotions right so i may or may
not have made a small bag after learning
how to trade crypto with leverage
okay and this bag is duplicating the
more i work and people talk about the
money i'm making
i also work as a waiter and do laboring
and therefore have substantial cash on
me at all
times everyone's got revenue streams boy
yeah say less okay however
i feel like the low-key success i'm
having is making it impossible
impossible for me to have a decent
long-lasting relationship
every time i go on a date i find the
girls always bring up the money and not
in a good way
more of a please spoil me way and i'm
not looking to be an atm with a tool
i also right this is the iron i also
drive a bmw
one series
at 18 man put in brackix flex i know i
know
which doesn't help my case
because i've just got straight hoes
chasing me
okay yeah okay like the pretty pretty
girls in my area that wouldn't even give
me a chance before now force
conversation and give me screw face
every time they see me
now all the decent girls think i'm
getting busy with the straight 12s in my
area because of the attention they give
me but it's really not the case because
i'm boring like that i want something
serious and lasting
okay
i regret ending my previous relationship
of 10 months because i felt uh that she
actually liked me
what she i felt like she actually liked
me
for me sort of thing i regret ending it
oh okay sorry i regretted it because she
did actually like me for me but then
again she became a controlling freak
since then i've had the opportunity to
run through some puss but i haven't uh
but i have it because i'm looking for
the one
should i just do what all my mates do
and rack up the numbers or should i wait
for the wifey
please advise me how to deal with my
conundrum
right
you say your bit and then i'll say my
bit i mean
i don't think it's
should i do what my mates do and run
through the puss or wait
it's one of those ones where it depends
on how you feel like
you could
regardless of your current every all
right
i think the ultimate goal for most
people in life is to find a person that
they can feel like they can spend their
time with you know regardless of whether
it be forever or if it be
you can see it happening
you're okay you're fine as it is blah
blah you know what i mean there's always
going to be that somewhat end goal i
believe
um so i don't necessarily think just
because you are looking for something
long-lasting
that you should or shouldn't rather
enjoy your teens
as an 18 year old it's understandable
like
in this day and age regardless of
how you look
as someone's status is going to be
important to someone else if that makes
it like my status isn't important to me
but my status might be important to
someone else yeah do you know what i
mean yeah so
i
as an 18 year old that drives an a1 you
say a1 no no i didn't say an a1 what
would you say i said a bmw
one series sorry a bmw one c was like 18
you've got like three sources of income
and you you always have cash on you
like that comes with the territory you
shouldn't know
you knew by getting a one series you
were gonna get attention so really bro
you're talking different to what i
thought you were gonna say really a one
series that's a [ __ ]
he's 18.
i know people that did learning lessons
in a one series
hey i think it as 18 year old
bro
you need to understand well not you need
to understand but i feel like drug
dealers in my head that were driving
c-class benzes at 18.
he's not a drug dealer but he's
obviously but i feel like as an 18 year
old
you're gonna get attention regardless of
not necessarily regardless of the car
you drive but
i feel like at his age that's a decent
car for reason yes that's what i'm
saying is not bad
so he's gonna get [ __ ] attention of
course he will yeah he's gonna get a bit
of [ __ ] but i feel like and he's got
money he's blowing it out of proportion
he is don't get me wrong he is blowing
out proportion don't get me wrong but i
also think that he knew what he was
doing he didn't he
not necessarily did it to get attention
and did it to get girls or whatever but
i also feel like
he can't necessarily
be mad at the fact that women want him
with or without the money but he's
trying to find
a lifelong thing like it's it's
inevitable this is life you're gonna
have to roll your dice and take it as it
is like you shouldn't be like because my
my boys are just having fun and like
sleeping around and blah blah blah
should i do that to you or should i wear
a big man do what you want how and as
and when you feel
yeah um
that's true
to be fair giving it some extra thought
something you said in there resonated
with me and it made me realize
cool
the stuff that you're talking about is
inevitable
but there is something like i said
there's something that happened in there
where like
the only reason people know you got
money because you told them you've got
money you're not famous
you told them that you're making money
from crypto and you do laboring and you
told them like oh you said like oh i've
always got cash in me or all times
they're not going through your pockets
you're showing them that you've got cash
on you at all times yeah so like if
that's the attention you're getting it's
the that's because that's the energy
you're putting out there yeah so you
can't really be mad that you're getting
um like attention from girls that don't
necessarily want you for you because
that's the way you're moving you're
moving that you don't
want girls who want you for you you're
moving like you want girls who want you
for money
um so whereas if you didn't tell anyone
that you were you were like quote
unquote like loaded or whatever it is
if if you were moving like that and no
one knew you had money then you'll
probably be with girls who like your ex
like you said
be that were with you for you yeah but
like you're buying a car regardless if i
think of one series of flex car you
clearly think it's a one one series of
flex car which means in your mindset
you've obviously bought a car that you
know is going to get you attention
because you're saying yourself i'm 18
i'm driving up one series it's a flex i
know i know so you're you're you're
doing things to flex you're carrying
cash around you at all times don't need
to
you're driving a car that you deem as a
flex don't need to
like and you're telling everyone that
you're making bags of crypto when you
don't need to
so like
yeah i would say act the way you want
like put the energy into the universe
that would reciprocate the energy you
want back if you want someone who wants
you for you then maybe you should act
like you want someone who wants you for
you thanks and if you want yes i just
want you to spoil them then maybe don't
act like you want a yacht who you want
to spoil facts what possible reason do
you have to have cash on you at all
times all times at 18. you i bro i get
fixed if there's a tenner in my wallet i
don't do i don't carry cash it lives on
pay for haircuts
so like
yeah that's that's what i would
definitely say
i was going to cuss you at first but now
put it in perspective so yeah i would
say
on an actual thing bro when i say well
i'm not gonna lie to you when he said
bro i'm 18 i'm driving on one series
last four chill out
chill
out because no offense it's the worst
bmw you can buy oh of course but it's
yeah that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying but if you said
oh i've got a one series i really like
one series i'm like oh gang and you're
18 well played sir they feel like i've
got a flex car and it's a one series i
want immediately my chest goes chill out
yeah yeah chill out
he wanted to crush him then
but
yes i took a step back i'm glad i spoke
first because it would have been
terrible advice for me because i would
have been like get over yourself no one
wants you for your money you're moving
like a waste man but i've had time to
reflect
reflect yeah it's a time to reflect on
my initial thought process yeah i would
definitely say change the way you're
moving and maybe you'll get the energy
as far as whether you should clap cheeks
or
do what you want bro cause it sounds
like you're saying oh i want to go who
wants me for me and i want to go for the
long one so if that's what you want then
why are you even asking if you should if
you should just [ __ ] random girls
because that's not what you want to do
then why would you even do it
yeah but obviously i do understand being
a teenager if this feel what the mans
are into it's kind of tough too it's
tough to not be to not be in the
pressure that peer pressure yeah yeah
especially if they deem you
as someone who has access to that
um
you're going to be tempted to just do it
but if you don't want to do it then
don't do it if you do want to do it do
it and
trust me one thing i will say that
actually is advice is that spectrum is
going to waver
there is no ever one black or white
there's no ever one person who's always
in it for the long haul and one person
who just wants to smash random girls
as you go through life you're going to
have peaks and troughs sometimes you're
going to want the wi-fi for this and
sometimes you're just going to want to
bang someone sucks so good luck with
that yeah that's going to come with it
but anyway yeah i would say
stop thinking about yourself as someone
who is so successful
you're describing yourself in these ways
that not necessarily everyone is
describing you you're identifying
yourself as a successful 18 year old who
has more money than others who can flex
more than others and it's just like the
way you view view yourself is not
conducive to getting the kind of person
that you're looking for yeah so just
change the way you're actually changing
your mentality yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
you don't mean to sound like a
narcissist but you are something yeah
yeah you're giving off some weird vibes
some weird ego vibes whereas like that's
why i got defensive
and i was like chill the [ __ ] out like
why are you talking about yourself like
this like oh i may or may not have made
a bag and the bag just duplicates
chill
chill out yeah yeah yeah yeah that comes
with age though so you'll yeah it will
get it will come it will happen
um anyway you said you got trash news no
uh yeah two seconds
oh so this is spiraling on from um what
you ranted about a few weeks ago i know
what you're going to say and i
you're livid go on you're living go on
you're living one gemma yeah
gemma owens go on plt
young signing already six figures six
figures six figure signing so just to
re-actually read the caption gemma urban
science six-figure deal with clothing
brand plt
um the love item finalist was reportedly
hand-picked by founder umar khamani and
his close team and we the first love
island contestant signed with plt after
multi-millionaire money meh who is now
the creative director and do you know
the peak thing about that there was a
poll on i've got the poll right here
there was a poll on
plt that plt
um actually did on twitter
tweet us tweet us using the hashtag
hashtag pltdeal if you think india would
be the perfect pa plt dog she got
according by the time this was
screenshot she got
um over 2 000 retweets and over 10 000
likes the same thing got posted for
gemma and it got put back to back she
got 185 retweets and 453 likes and she
got it
also we're some racists up in here now
is that what you're telling me if you
had that's what it is it's a racist now
this is what the story is looking like
i'm not going to lie to you bro
i'm not and literally after that it's
official gemma owen we can't wait to
work with you blah blah blah blah blah
but
india that everyone know you know like
people that even watched the show that
loved india you know what i mean i swear
and it's like so it's a conspiracy
like gemma
the only thing i would say i liked about
gemma in the show like because i don't
know obviously i don't know any of them
but the only thing i would i say i'd
liked about gemma in the show is her
integrity she's stuck she always
she
she spoke what she thought but
with sense as opposed to just chatting
[ __ ] yeah and she always stuck to her
her guns on her ground which is why i i
like that she's wasn't she the you of
them she's 19. so she's nine yeah she's
she is very mature in the way she
communicates and how she thinks about
certain things but i don't
like this was unnecessary like the fact
the sheer fact that she's michael owen's
daughter
is is enough for
me and everyone to think like one you
don't need to be on the show yeah two
the age gap between you and the bread of
your whip
was borderline do you know what i mean
and it's like
the fans wanted india to be on this plt
thing it's clear
it's clear i'm trying to find
quantitative data quad i'm trying to
actually find the non-screen shots
because it was someone else that screen
showed it obviously not plt so i'm gonna
see if i can actually find the pictures
that he put
if they've not deleted it but if they
have i must have deleted it surely
there's no way oh sorry if they haven't
i'm i'm very very intrigued so they must
have deleted it yeah no way they can
have that level of evidence just on the
internet
yeah they must have it because i'm
looking at like last week now yeah yeah
just dropped when there's some total
[ __ ] oh yeah it was to be fair it was a
month ago
it was a month ago so let me see if i
can find it keep talking let me see if i
can find the original hang on you mean
to tell me yeah because they gave they
threw neller a bone
that these men can do what they want
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] because they've got a
little a little a little line [ __ ]
that's our black quarter done for the
year [ __ ] that's our diversity done yeah
yeah yeah that's literally our dancing
races now okay say let's say they said i
said i said let's see because it's fine
that's fine that's that's insanity
though bro like public wanted that's
fine they public vaulted they literally
voted and you chose the opposite that's
fine that's fine that's fine that's fine
you know what i think they've taken it
down yeah of course they've taken it
down why would they leave it up there
yeah wait what are we in we're in august
in it
wait let me go back hold on hold on i
think they've definitely taken it out if
someone doesn't pat an india deal before
we get back from holiday yeah i'm going
to be livid i'm going to cause a rock
i'm going to be living gonna cause a
ruckus
she needs some bro she needs simon son
quick she needs something yeah maybe i
don't know i'm not saying anything
disparaging maybe a little invisalign
deal let's like shield two birds one
stone like this less
let's sort satin out yeah
it needs to be six figures and it needs
to happen in the next week yeah
because otherwise i'm gonna start
running my mouth
where's the deals where's money
the melanin
where are they where literally where are
they where are they where are they
because this is becoming a running theme
where oh yeah this is gone bro it's the
lead it's not anywhere
what's michael owen's daughter it's not
anywhere she's caked she's fine
bro this is wow this is nuts
this is nuts
i need to find out
someone needs to tell me that they did
the right thing and hollared india and
she said no no yeah that's what i need
to learn in the next seven days if
there's not a deal on the table
if there's not deal on the table bro
someone better come out and be like yo
calm down
we offered her india said no she said no
india we need to know did you say no
yeah india we know you watch the show
come out did you say no or not because
we can't we can't stand for this anymore
yeah this we can't just keep this up
this is some [ __ ] where are your
deals yeah
you deserve all the deals where are you
we want you on the deals bro and this is
not patterning for us
it's not okay it's not sitting well with
us it's not okay so what the [ __ ] is
going on what is actually going on
what's actually going on because this
behind from yeah from where i'm sitting
you man are moving
cases
and i don't like it yeah yeah it's nuts
it's not bro as soon as i read that i
was like raw because i saw the tweet
first the comparison tweet
the likes and retweets and then i saw
the um
the instagram post who's her management
please
who's india's management
because what's going on what is going on
yeah
what is going on she had it patterned
from the first week in the show
wait did she did she come second i think
yeah i think they came second
this is something [ __ ] yeah
yeah six figure plt teams six she
doesn't she's 19. but it does the age is
irrelevant ages
but still bro
like i think was like 21. to be fair
take away the age take away who her dad
is
let's just treat it like any other
civilian let's just stick to the facts
whether she needs it because it's not
we're not talking charity now yeah we're
talking about business deals yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the [ __ ] that oh she doesn't need the
money [ __ ] all that chat because we're
talking business
if the mandem said we want india to be
the thing
and then
because the numbers you just said were a
joke yeah the difference was the
difference was staggering ridiculous
ridiculous i need to find out she turned
it down i need to find out she turned it
down ridiculous bro
all right say let's she turned it down
and that's the narrative i'm gonna until
someone proves me yeah wrong that's the
narrative that's the narrative that's
only gonna allow me to sleep yeah yeah
because
things aren't adding up yeah things
aren't they really aren't they're not
adding up
they had the audacity to put them back
to back and then they reposted and said
oh congratulations welcome to our new
welcome our new plt blah blah blah we're
a must have been flabbergasted oh yeah
rags rags i already know it black
twitter would have kicked up her yes
someone run her a deal before this gets
out of hand yeah before we get back from
madeira yeah yeah we need to see
deals on instagram and twitter we want
to see deals on the table we need to we
need to see deals on the table because
otherwise shit's gonna get nasty it will
it will yeah it actually will because i
don't understand this love-hate
relationship yeah i don't get it because
in the show you love us in the show you
loved india you loved her yeah everyone
in the nation did yeah come out now
trying to secure a couple bags nothing
no one wants to pipe up nothing so
seven days
we'll see you then yeah i'm not making
threats i'm just saying we're just
saying it's best for everyone if i find
out the truth in the next seven days
that's all we're saying right ig
questions that's it and we're gonna
we're gonna wrap it up with that um so
this week guys we asked you what's the
one thing that kept you from baking that
baking from breaking up with someone and
as per juicy responses guys let's go i'm
going to bang bang bang bang bang
through all right
he had that devil dick that was hard to
say no to oh god the sheer facts he owed
me 3k at my mum 1k
she stayed with him because
he owed bags
she stayed because he owes me money
money
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
money to owe your partner and your mum
1k
that's a lot of money yeah nest you man
absolutely you're never getting that
back never why would i give it to you
back the mum is hounding them
tell your little boyfriend
tell your little scumbag boyfriend to
run my money four bags well you're
paying for that
that's a joke
he's multiple fake suicide attempts
bro i bet that is a running theme oh
there was bag of suicide ones of course
i couldn't believe it that's a joke i
couldn't believe
old rich parents with health issues
man was waiting wow
i was going out with a guy who was
really abusive but i loved his dog
tapped fam i thought dog was a euphemism
tapped bro the actual pet tapped [ __ ]
sake go on she liked doing house chores
lazy you lazy fart wow
that psycho [ __ ] hit different
yes please
yes
please oh doesn't it it doesn't it just
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my birthday was a month longer so i hung
out for that [ __ ] that ah that's dead
her mum was giving me [ __ ] on the side
along with a hot meal
[Laughter]
wow
and plus if you're ready to break up
with her then you already know you've
got nothing to lose yeah if this comes
to light you don't care you don't care
that's their mom and daughter business
yeah you're leaving
on a hot meal
he got me pregnant and i felt like i
owed it to him since i didn't keep it
jesus christ
his potential
still lazy as [ __ ] after all these years
thank god i left him
his potent
shame on her facts shame on her don't
ever judge me on my potential
take me for me take me for who i am yeah
my potential
[ __ ] you
don't ever judge me on my potential
oh those jokes oh gosh three winters in
a row i was promised a canada goose i
left at the fourth with no goose
bro i
you know it was as well i stayed with
someone for over a year longer because i
was promised a birthday threesome oh
it never [ __ ] even came gross
every year
i was promised this birthday three-way
and it never happened
women love to
gas men at the beginning of situation
ships
and never pull through and it's
excellent you have no intentions you
have no intention they say it because
they know it's going to keep us like
these four walls you keep us gas this
goes unreal this girl is like there's no
other girl that's talking like this yeah
so of course i'm going to stay with you
yeah yeah and whichever female you bring
into this party yeah yeah do you know
what i mean a year later what i bring up
freeze again what the [ __ ] are you
talking about recently i love you yeah
yeah yeah you think i'm gonna love
another [ __ ] in this house i love you
bro she finn she's been mean
[Music]
once i realized it was two years in
before i realized i'm not ever having
this reason
i'm not ever gonna have it
and then she gaslit me because when i
brought it up she was like are you just
with me for this teresa and i'm like
whoa whoa whoa whoa
i'm just honestly i promise
what you brought up so i'm saying where
is it
are you just with me
oh she would have put you on the ropes
oh [ __ ] that's hilarious all right back
to it
what's the one thing that kept you from
breaking up with someone
he'd always
he'd always trap me in the house
whenever i tried to leave bro what
she had the best toes in the area
that what does that even mean james
in
jesus
threats of suicide the liar is still
alive
jesus christ her tit wanks were insane
oh gosh i would stay too yeah i would i
would stay tuned
with a little
plural with a helmet
yeah i'm not going anywhere yeah keep me
she threatens every day that she'll tell
someone that she [ __ ] me in the ass
that's verbal leave me i'm telling
everyone you i [ __ ] you in the ass if
you dare leave i'm telling every i'm
telling your boys i stuffed you
wow
i was sleeping with his twin on the side
got to see both of them when i stayed
over
that's a dirty dynamic bro random
spoiler because you're not going to
watch it anyway there is a scene in
sandman i am i said i literally said to
you i'm going to watch it you said you
weren't going to watch it no mine carry
on
is it a huge spoiler it's like a oh yeah
it is okay not to the not to the story
yeah but to that episode you're like oh
[ __ ]
one guy says something outlandish to a
chick
outlandish sailor and you're like
[ __ ] now let's see yeah
i don't think i'd find another woman
with tits like hers oh god that sounds
like one of my boys he'll do anything
for us
yeah for a healthy pair he'll do
anything
anything
that's hilarious
he stabbed his arm with a chisel twice
fam what is wrong with people oh my god
matters of the heart they they can't
handle this literally do or die they
can't handle it she's by it and we have
ffm threesomes all the time
exactly what i just said
exactly what i've just said
you the way you bit yourself that's
exactly what would have kept me there
for another two years
if she actually played ball with me all
of the time all the time ffms all the
time
bro to be fair though actually
saying that i don't know if i'll be that
interested with my girl every time yeah
see it's obviously very different yeah
very different but still
it's still
still baggage yeah we had already paid
for our wedding
and you didn't want to be there so you
got married
so you doubled down and got married oh
god
i had already booked a trip to dublin
and i didn't want to go by myself
well the amount of people that i know
that have gone on holidays with their ex
because they'd already booked the
[ __ ] thing
is
mad to me especially when it ends
horribly
yeah like i know a girl who
found out her man was cheating
so they broke up and they still went on
holiday
and it was already pre-paid for an hour
yeah he's already pre-paid just because
they'd paid for it nah man and it's like
yeah but now you're just paying for
torture no what would you what would how
was that holiday did you do you ask you
don't i didn't care that's as soon as
she said she was going i was i literally
your friend was the girl not the guy my
friend was the girl okay yeah yeah as
soon as she told me that we were still
going on holiday and stuff i was like
i don't even want to talk to you yeah
because you're just a [ __ ] idiot i
can't entertain myself being gone from
your account so just leave just leave it
yeah
you're going to spend more money you've
got to spend more money out there
someone you hate yeah it's just dumb huh
and you're probably going to bang him
anyway they of course they're going to
bang of course they're going to
hate [ __ ] yeah they're going to have one
hit [ __ ] that's going to send both of
them loopy oh they're going to nut and
hold hands yeah rags rags rags rags and
she's going to smack him in his chest
after like how [ __ ] dare you you did
this yeah you did she's going to break
the [ __ ] down crying
yeah it's not that's exactly okay she's
going to not he's going to knock she's
gonna play a little game yeah like i
[ __ ] hate you like i actually hate
you and then she's gonna break down
crying because she's gonna realize like
i actually hate you yeah like you broke
my [ __ ] heart how could you and now
she's hitting you for real yeah and then
this whole holiday is it's just hell
honestly it's hell bro it's hell on
earth and you're gonna recycle that
every night yeah for the whole week
ah stupid anyway
the secret wow the secret house i'd
bought behind his back wasn't ready to
move into yet
fam
oh god she threatened to take my dogs
away oh what oh
what
are they your dogs or not she's trying
to take my dogs yeah
the water pressure at his apartment was
better than that that would make me save
or something i knew that would make me
stay with someone bro
[ __ ] now good water pressure
ever forget it i'm going to remodel my
house after that shower oh it was a nice
shower in it press a button full of
pressure perfect heat
what that's fantastic what's one of the
best shots i've ever had banging it was
much better than the um hotel we started
in edinburgh the water pressure was that
was [ __ ] it was so thorough those
showers were [ __ ] there was so much the
whole ensemble of the room was banging
the lighting was unbelievable did you
ever sleep with the night light of
course the red light i did red red red
red in my room the bathroom on the
toilet god
[Laughter]
night mode pressed it
[Music]
yeah it was sick
oh okay i got three more very cool [ __ ]
that sweet me
i couldn't be asked unloading all my
weird kinks and fetishes with someone
else again oh that's a woman that's a
magnet that was a guy oh really
yeah
that was a guy
she was the popular girl in school oh
[ __ ] that reminded me of
that reminded me of you when you said
about that bang in chicken secondary
school
that the bread broke up with her
and then you were like oh in year eight
yeah
and then she said twins
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
live it bro live it that story when you
told it that day i was dying bro [ __ ]
piss me off man twinsies twinsies
twins yeah i couldn't believe it broke
my heart i couldn't believe it like last
one i thought i wouldn't be able to live
without him the thought of it gave me
chest pains and anxiety
that's
oh that's codependency
it could be credibility it also could be
massive manipulation oh 100 oh yeah yeah
he could have convinced you that you're
useless you're useless without me and
you will die single yeah yeah stay with
me why would you possibly think anyone
else would want you but me
[ __ ] how could you ever think anyone
would ever want you except for me
what goes through people's minds to say
that to another human being you should
like that all the time that's in i the
thing is
i obviously will never know what it's
like to be a woman but i would like to
think
if i was a woman i would still have the
mentality of foo had i would love to
think that so i'm trying to put my shoes
i'm trying to put myself in her shoes
after reading now after what we just
said
and i
can't fathom keeping quiet if a man said
to me
do you think you'll ever find love if
you left me right now
i would want to fight him do you know
what i mean bro i would want to [ __ ]
strangle the life out of it yeah bro
like who are you
who do you think you are yeah rags rags
oh it's it's madness yeah some people
madness
but yeah that was um that was the
question of the week guys hope you
enjoyed it and that was that's that's
the end of the episode yeah man that's
it guys so thank you very much um
obviously head on over to patreon and
we'll catch you on thursday but in the
meantime guys love love
[Music]